[Music]
hi checking in its what's 45th birthday
soiree years this place has its own
magic I think you're gonna look smell
nice this is such a great spread on a
wiener watch fingers sweetie it it's
nice to get away and unplug this place
is just so relaxing time to get our buns
in gear for our thoughtful hunt so is
that a plan my caddy today we have birds
of prey watching it's nice to get a
break from the group right honestly I
just need a drink we're doing whatever
the f we want
[Music]
Catherine where's your face so tight did
you put on a night cream bundiada
bundiada bundiada bundiada I was her
diagnosis and she's mentally quite sound
great thing about life you can feel fine
but I also know that you're a ticking
time bomb
why do you have to be so controlling
about everything I just want to say I'm
now ready to forgive all of your
bundiada boom
[Music]
you